the military analyst former air Vice
Marshall Sean Bell is here uh Sean tell
us first of all uh what you know about
that delete Pro attack it was the latest
wave of Russian strikes missile strikes
across the country and in the past 24
hours and as you say it look appears the
hospital to meet Pro was struck uh
casualties two died and but the number
of injured is growing each time we
report on it it's north of 30 at the
moment when you see some of the
devastation it's no great surprise I
suspect that will increase even further
the Russian style attacks were against
Kiev and a whole variety of different
targets the ukrainians claim that
they've shot down uh 10 missiles and 20
drones but inevitably some get through
there were two oil facilities at kharkiv
that were also struck twice last night
the Russians appeared to be targeting
Ukrainian Logistics support which of
course in anticipation of their spring
offensive is expected but also Russian
tactics seem to be now that they're
attacking different cities on different
nights to try to Deluge the air defense
systems of Ukraine and despite however
effective they are at doing that some
inevitably get through all right and
what about this news that Russia is
moving ahead uh with its decision to
deploy tactical nuclear weapons to
Belarus we first broke this in March
because President Putin announced he was
going to forward deploy uh tactical
nuclear weapons into Belarus yesterday
the two respective defense ministers met
and signed up the requisite paperwork in
fact president lukashenko left that and
then said that the missiles were already
on their way but we understand the
special storage facilities that are
required won't be actually available to
the end of the end of the month now face
value this is more about shaking the um
the rhetoric around nuclear and putting
a threat and putting fear into the West
because the harsh reality is you don't
have to forward deploy nuclear weapons
they are they can travel halfway around
the world so there's no benefit and
they're really unlikely to actually ever
be used so what's the real story here
the real story is that President Putin's
made no secret of his desire trying to
increase Russian influence restore the
Soviet Union he's invaded Ukraine and
he's actually installed a puppet regime
in lukashenko across in in Belarus he's
increasingly been putting more soldiers
on the ground at Belarus by conducting
operations against Ukraine from that
soil air attacks from there now putting
nuclear weapons in there as well all
designed to increase Russian influence
in Belarus but importantly put more
soldiers into Belarus itself now
lukashenko he's kept in power by Putin
he's been described as the last dictator
in Europe
um and although he's got he he's got a
really difficult line to tread because
he wants to avoid riots which he's had
in the past
um but he also doesn't want to keep out
of step with President Putin apparently
he was fairly lukewarm about some of the
initiatives Putin had to get even closer
a line between the two countries
coincidentally his health declined
around that time but he's only recently
been seen seen back again but let's be
quite clear this initiative about the
the nuclear weapons being deployed is
from be less for an international
audience and has almost certainly Russia
just tightening the Noose gently around
Belarus this is a Russian invasion of
Belarus or a phase of it but by stealth
very interesting stuff and want to keep
an eye on thank you very much Sean Bell